but vaginas are just as ugly to me
that's what it looks like it's a mother
straight sideways you know what I'm not
gonna have chaos dance dot because that
is sexual this is where the first ones
to [ __ ] everything it's true no it was
in high school
dancers were the ones that were the most
sexually active they were the most
talking about I had this and that so
quiet when did you lose your virginity
oh no no no your virginity listen when I
had care in high school that time that's
the question I'm gonna tell you that but
here's the thing I had a boyfriend for
three years he was plenty Wilder and you
were not eighteen when did you lose your
virginity because if you tell the world
you're not a horrible I do they're like
[ __ ] hop in [ __ ] it doesn't make you a
[ __ ] it's just it's just the question
you've not a skank if you lost your
virginity early your experimental that's
why I don't want to like label my kid so
if my kid has he'll sec sixteen fifteen
fourteen whatever she knows that I had
sex on the sidewalk your [ __ ] dude my
first boyfriend why lost atubu in the
way older than me I found out when I
lost the to him he got his girl pregnant
his
you mean like who was this ghetto ass
[ __ ]
lost your virginity it was like in the
beginning of our relationship where he
was like oh let's have sex sounds like
I'm scared and we had sex and then I
found out so what age were you when you
lost your virginity just cool but why
does it matter cuz it did your dog's the
disease later odd when did you lose your
virginity
I loaned my virginity at the age of 17
Oh handsome yeah I was late I was in
high school is that late High School's
flakes well I think late for my group of
friends so by that time everybody was
[ __ ] they were [ __ ] at the time
they were like 14 15 so I was the late
bloomer when we would come over to one
of my friend's house you don't feel
people they're known to be very sexually
active even his dad so because I would
never come over with the curve right I
would never come over with the girl and
all these things are talking about
[ __ ] and he was very open with his
dad and his dad was very proud that his
son was [ __ ] the [ __ ] on everything
you would come up to me buzz hey David
why you don't like buzz buzz I was so
cross no way are you I I'm not getting
you you would ask me if I like [ __ ] cuz
he thought I was gay
cuz he lost your virginity at 17
because I will never bring a girl round
so here I was a virgin at the time and I
just and to be honest with you during
that time it's not like [ __ ] was like
an opportunity that I had let them miles
a very awkward child I liked one girl at
the time I only like one girl was it
that girl I lost my virginity yeah yes
yeah so I had like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
homing missile it was the one that I
wanted nothing you hear how I talk about
love oh boo cannot make love you got
[ __ ] it was actually really sad I was
just laying there with my white brussels
sweater still on and I was like but
you're crying I was just like it's okay
and then we let I like asked him to
leave I was like can you please leave
like don't stay and I took a hot shower
like like a [ __ ] TV drama and I
started crying like a little [ __ ] in
the boy friend I was like I'm a [ __ ]
then why did you do it cuz I'm stupid so
you got pressure is easily altered baby
I'm not even so much scared that much I
was gonna have said I'm afraid that
she's not gonna have sex on her own
terms
yeah
[Music]
you know what I mean so the interchange
is like so so in your case you didn't
want and it was an older person and they
kind of influenced her right I don't I
don't want that so by the time I listen
she's like 16 and then she has sex with
another kid that's 16 or 17 something
around the similar age right yeah and
then they were both in a very loving
relationship and they wanted it was like
okay that's great but see in your case
you didn't want it you felt pressured
and then your thought you were all or
after yes then I turned into a [ __ ] I'm
just joking on that yes I am
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]